we are once again partnering with our
good pals at AT&T this time to bring you
a 1-hour pre-show live from the roof of
the glorious Spreckels theaters it's
called Conan 360 live it is broadcast
entirely in 360 degree virtual reality
and hosted by very funny comedians Chris
red and Moses storm and he's wearing a
VR headset so we can say hi do you see
Chris and Moses Andy I do there they are
they're right in front of me it's like I
can touch them yeah they're on the
rooftop right now and I think there they
are yes yes
[Applause]
yeah it's beautiful what a sad scent we
build for them yeah it looks yeah it's a
rejected outhouse from a Jurassic Park
yeah really it's really more of an
encampment oh we're sorry guys but
you're doing a great job and guess what
our conan's freaks this oh look there
was some AT&T signage there and you
don't accidentally look down and see
that oh my goodness where are my legs
they took my legs guess what our Conan
360 live pre-show has three other
cameras we got Stage Door
that's right Stage Door there it is yeah
pretty amazing inside the theater yeah
I guess that's Alavi can we have the
audience area right here with the stages
let's see that
oh yeah your your legs are still calm
and your legs are still there
you can watch you look like a fool you
can watch as opposed to me in the suit
you can watch the VR pre shows on our
team Copa Facebook YouTube channels and
at team coca calm / 360 thanks to our
pals at AT&T we'll be right back
you